hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
immunological profiling using multiple
model systems to understand sars
kobe 2 infection i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation i'd now
like to welcome our speakers
the first speaker dr primnath roger
canoe will be
introducing the audience to quantity
gene plex technology
and technical validation data provided
by the collaborator
and our second speaker dr claudio
venezia
will be presenting work done in dr mara
biasin's
lab at the university of milan italy
welcome to both of you you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for the kind introduction
today we are going to talk about
immunological profiling
using multiple model systems to
understand sars cop2 infections
coronavirus are a large family of
viruses that are known to cause various
diseases in humans
camels bats and cattle there are seven
different coronaviruses that are known
to infect humans
from the first time they were identified
in the 1960s
mers saskov and the 2019 novel
coronavirus
also known as the south code 2 are known
to have crossed
over from animals to humans fast scope 2
which is the focus of the stock is a
positive single stranded rna virus
with a genome size of 30 kilobase pair
the virus affects primarily the lung
epithelial cells of the host organism
the whole system's heightened
inflammatory response invokes the
cytokine storm
causing collateral damage to the lungs
and increment pneumonia
an urgent need to study not only the
viral pathogenesis
but also the adverse host immune
response calls for the use of
multi-parametric molecular assays
that can simultaneously quantify the
viral
and relevant host molecular markers
luminex xmap technology is best built on
super paramagnetic particle coated
spherical microbeads
these beads carry carboxyl groups that
can
covalently bind with amide groups from
antibodies
peptides and nucleic acids these beads
are then filled with a specific
proportion of red and far red dyes
giving rise to 100 different
combinations of bead sets
with the unique red to far red dye ratio
each b set opening to its surface
carboxyl chemistry
are coupled with target specific capture
probes and can be mixed together in a
single reaction to perform
multiplexing rna or protein
quantification
the beads are measured using different
luminex instruments
one type of instrument functions like a
flow cytometer
where a red laser measures the red to
far red die ratio
identifying the bead set or the target
and the green laser
measures the number of fluorophores
bound to the beads hence giving us the
quantification
of the bound target molecule the second
type of
instrument is a fluorescent imager where
the lasers are replaced by led lamps
and fluorescence is measured by sacd
camera
let me introduce you to quantity gentlex
assay technology quanta geneplex is a
multiplexing rna quantification method
that combines branch dna technology and
the luminex
xmap technology quantigene is an in-situ
hybridization-based method
where samples such as cells tissues or
whole blood from a range of species
can be directly used to quantify up to
80 rna targets
simultaneously the samples are
homogenized using specific buffers
containing rna stabilizing agents and
the target rna is captured
and quantified using multiple small dna
probes
the most prominent feature of the
technology is that it does not require
rna isolation
and no reverse transcription of mrna to
cdna like in a qpcr method
making the method free from any
enzymatic conversion bias
here is an animation explaining how the
technology
works first a spectrally coded
luminex xmap beads are customized
to capture several mrna targets within
your
desired panel small dna probes
specifically designed to hybridize with
different regions across the mrna
sequence is allowed to cooperatively
hybridize with a target mrna molecule
once the capture hybridization is
complete
the branch dna probes are sequentially
added to generate the signal
amplification step
the endpoint fluorescent signal is
generated by
thousands of fluorophores that bind to
these branch dna structures
by exploiting the power of xmap
technology and the highly specific
branch dna technology
we are able to reliably quantify up to
80
mrna targets including normalizing genes
in each reaction well
to help scientists working on source
scope to research
we now have a pre-configured quantity
and flex 50 flex catalog panel
typically quantagine flex panels are
custom designed
and manufactured but the significance of
cytokine storm
in kobe 19 disease drove us to build
this panel
that would help scientists investigate
the host immune response
while simultaneously quantifying the
viral load in the host system
we have further extended the viral
targets to also cover influenza
and rsv viral species to help
specifically understand
kobe 19 related immune biomarkers in
relation to other viral respiratory
diseases
the panel also includes five carefully
selected housekeeper genes
that can be used for normalizing or
relative gene expression signals
if the user wishes to customize this
preset panel
this is certainly possible by simply
adding your genes of interest to this
existing list
with the help of our design team
here is the genomic map of the source
corporate virus rohan isolate
its genome is 30 kilobyte space long
consisting of 10 coding regions
in the quantum virus hosts host 50plex
panel we have designed probes
targeting various coding regions
spanning the entire genomic sequence of
the virus
such a design gives the possibility not
only to quantify the virus with high
sensitivity
but also help characterize specific
structural
and functional genes that might be
involved in the pathogenesis
two separate virus host panels have been
designed
and developed to be used in human and
mouse species
as several research groups are employing
both mouse and human models
to understand the pathogenesis and
related host immune modulations
these two model species specific panels
can be useful in translational research
the information about the targets and
ordering of these
panels can be found under these links on
the thermofish scientific website
also more detailed information and
related literature
on quantity and flex assays can also be
found under the link you see on the
slide
we collaborated extensively with
research groups from the university of
milan in italy
and from the university of tennessee
memphis in the united states
in the next few minutes i would like to
present some validation data
from our collaborators work
on this slide i'd like to show you the
sensitivity and dilution recovery of the
various soft scope to quanta gene probe
sets
on the left is a dilution series of
source code 2
rna from an italian isolate measured
using the human panel
a great linearity was observed for viral
target
probes are very high dilutions of the
viral rna
viral copies as little as 150 to 200
copies
were measured reliably using the pan
probe on the right
you see a similar dilution series of
isolated total rna
from mouse lung tissue measured also
using a mouse panel
the mouse was infected with source co2
virus
a signal saturation for the pan source
co2 probe
was observed at amounts less than 100
nanograms of rna
this is reflected in the linearity
coefficient values that you see on the
graph
inferring that the virus can be
quantified using a very little amount of
total tissue rna
both the human and mouse panels use
identical designs for the viral targets
this slide shows the signal saturation
of rsv probes
from a sample spiked with reference rsv
rna
the measurement was performed using the
human 50 plex panel
as we can see in the raw data chart
signals were measured with very good
linearity exclusively for the rsv probes
while the influenza and sas cop2 probes
showed mere background signals this
showcases
the exemplary specificity of the probe
design in the quantogen assay
in another experiment the collaborators
from milan
used a549 lung epithelial carcinoma
cells as in vitroscope 2 lung infection
model
a549 cells were transfected with
different orbs
of either human or bad coronavirus cells
were lysed
and measured using quantity in flex 50
plex human panel
you can see that the transfected source
code to orbs were specifically measured
in the respective samples
however or 8 is highly conserved across
bat and human coronavirus
and this can be seen by strong and
comparable signals
between the or eight human and or eight
batch samples
as or three c and seven b are not a part
of the panel
they do not show any signal in the
translated cells
this data from the memphis group shows
the specificity and sensitivity of the
quantity gene assay
in human cell culture infection model
primary tracheal epithelial cells were
infected with different isolates of
source co2 for 24
hours the cells were lysed using sample
specific buffer
and the license were diluted and
directly subjected to quantagine
analysis
the graph on the top shows normalized
gene expression of viral targets
and the bottom graph shows log
transformed normalized gene expression
of host immune response targets all
three different isolates were able to
infect the tracheal epithelial cells
and invoke a response that was measured
in a multiplexing manner from the cell
lysis
this figure illustrates once again the
sensitivity of the source co2 probes in
the assay
the culture wells were used directly to
prepare the lysis and approximately
70 thousand cells per well were used the
x-axis in the figure
shows sample lies at dilutions and the
y-axis shows the background subtracted
fluorescence signal values
as you can see even at one to two
hundred sample dilution
the source coke cop2 targets and the
most host
human targets were reliably quantified
finally this data from milan group shows
immune response to source cove to
and influenza inflection on xvivo human
pbmc infection model
healthy human donor pbmcs were
stimulated with influenza
or source co2 virus and the pbmcs were
lysed
and directly used to quantify viral and
human inflammatory markers
log pole change of normalized gene
expression of flu stimulated pbmcs
over unstimulated ppmcs and sascov2
stimulated pvmcs
over unstimulated ppmcs is represented
in this graph
this experiment used only 100 000 ppmcs
to quantify 50 targets
simultaneously in each sample
it is worthy to note that the influenza
info invoked a stronger inflammatory
response
compared to the source code to infection
this now nicely sets the stage for me to
hand over the talk
to a collaborator dr claudio finiccia
from the university of miller
thank you for the introduction i will
now take over and present you
some of our results upon virus detection
our body quickly reacts and orchestrates
a complex multi-phased
immune response together target cells
employ intracellular innate antiviral
mechanisms to contain
viral infection and replication as
immunologists of viral infectious
diseases
an expertise of ours is to investigate
immune correlation of protection from
infection
versus susceptibility and progression to
disease
over the last decade we significantly
contributed to the characterization of
several immune related pathways
relevant in the antiviral immune
response
in particular we have been investigating
the role of cytokines and chemicals
production
pathogen recognition receptors the
inflammasome
the interferon stimulated genes and the
regulation of the cholesterol metabolism
as one of them
and the antigen presentation mechanism
among other pathways
since the current sarcop2 pandemic first
raged
the urgent need to define relevant
immune correlates and dissect
infection and immunological mechanism
has been mandatory
we committed to quickly scan a wide
range of immunological pathways
relatively involved in the antiviral
response against
cellscop2 we diversified our researches
on different models
lung biopsies as relevant issues of a
respiratory infection
ex vivo peripheral blood nuclear cells
and finally we pursued the
characterization of long-term immune
response in a cohort of women who just
gave birth
in this first project i would like to
present you we characterized
the monological features of lung removed
from the first two italian subjects who
successfully underwent
emergency bilateral lung transplantation
due to covet-related acute respiratory
distress syndrome
removed lungs underwent
histopathological
evaluation gene expression profiling
for immune related signature was
performed
on lung biopsies and suscope 2
stimulated peripheral blood mononuclear
cells
moreover cytokine levels were measured
on plasma
and on bronchreviral labash
specimens
microscopic examination of the removed
lines
on the left showed widespread parenchyma
thickening
and signs of fibrosis at the microscopic
level on the right
a moderate inflammatory infiltrate was
present
in both cases mostly in the form of
lymphocytes with the prevalence of the
cds positive t cells compared
to the cd4 positive t cells components
in regard to the b cells infiltrate
scattered cd20 positive lymphocytes were
observed
on the left lung from covenanting
subject displayed an immune activated
profile
such hyperactivation was evident in
lungs from both
subjects with a sharp upregulation of
genes involved in different aspects of
the antiviral immune response
the signature included a sector
cytokines and chemokines
pathogen recognition receptors immune
activation receptor inflammasome
components
moreover interferon stimulated genes
including cholesterol metabolism were
greatly overexpressed
this is a relevant piece of data as
there is a lot going on about
interferon in covenant in patients who
often are surprisingly lacking plasmatic
interferon alpha protein
in severe to critical cases
furthermore in the center this
hyperactivated profile was more evident
in lungs from subject one indeed i would
like to draw your attention on
interleukin-6
il-6 which greatly arise between
subjects together with the receptors
involved in susceptible infections such
as h2
and the virus interacting protein agtr1
on the right ace to expression
in the lung parenchyma of cognitive lung
transplanted subjects
was evaluated at the protein level
indeed by monitor chemistry
we found that h2 was present both in the
alvera space
and the primary bronchus besides being
expressed
by small vessels as expected
in line with the general expression
pattern observed in lung tissues
plasmatic brain inflammatory antiviral
cytokines and chemokines were
upregulated with higher level in subject
1 compared
with subject 2. in particular we found
ccl3 interlocking 1 interokin6 ip10
and mcp1 being highly expressed
among other targets unfortunately
we couldn't retrieve blonde carver
lavage from subject two
and here is depicted in the center
subject one compared to a non-copied
related lung transplantation
analysis performed on the bile fluid
showed that
chemokines such as cr3 and cell 5 and
the transformatory molecules
il-1 and s6 were significantly higher
in the bulb from the kobe subject
specifically we observed a common
signature
in the plasma and in the bowel of
upregulated signaling molecules involved
in macrophages activation
which included chemistry and cytokines
such as ccl3 and
mcp1 and the intelligence and interferon
at the gene expression level pbncs from
both
covalent covenanting lung transplanted
subject displayed a strong immune
activation provides
both a body condition on the left and
upon stimulation disaster of two
specific antigens
on the right notably such
hyperactivation status was
higher in subject one with the
regulation
of a sector cytokines and chemicals
pathogen recognition receptors
immune activation receptors and
inflammation components
together with the gene expression data
the quantification of the cytokines in
the supernatants
from the culture of the pbmcs on the
right
confirmed that circulating lymphocytes
from both subjects were characterized by
pro-inflammatory phenotype in particular
high levels of monocytes macrophagic
hemotactic
and activating factors such as scissor 3
4 and g csf and the proflamatory
cytokines
such as il6 and tnf
briefly in conclusion we found that
if the pathological analysis show an
extensive
fibrotic remodeling are combined by an
immune infiltration
mrna profiling on lungs ambiences
show a hyperactivation or inflammatory
pathways
cytokines and chemicals profiling in
plasma and imbala
confirms the pro-inflammatory profile as
seen by
mrna analysis you can find the results
and and others in the published paper
reported here
in the second study design our aim was
the profiling
of the immune response triggered by
different microbial and inflammatory
stimuli
in order to do that we used inactivated
esoskop2
hiv and flu viruses together with
interferon alpha or iron beta
stimulation
and exposure to cmv antigens or
bacterial antigens
the cellular model employed was pbmc is
isolated from
healthy donor in this case
we use the quantigen technology to
profile the specific activation
signatures related to each tested
pathogen
notably the gene expression pattern was
partially shared by all the stimuli
employed and partially pathogen-specific
as summarized
in the reported heat map in particular
following inactivated task of 2
stimulation
a significantly higher transcription
rate was observed for
chemokines such as ccl2 3
5 and interruption 8. cytokines
such as ielts 1 beta
and 136 center from gamma inflammation
components
such as picard and casp1 and several
intestinal stimulated genes such as mx1
effect 1 m3 this approach therefore
allowed us to quickly point out the
modification trigger by pathogen
exposure at respective atomic level
energy control even in absence of an
actual infection
oh in the lack of time i don't want to
go deeper into details which you can
find
here in the published manuscript about a
broader study focus
on antigen presentation related
mechanism
as third and last study we investigated
the new response
against suscop2 in pregnant women
it is well established that pregnancy
induces these changes in the immune
system
this is part of the physiological
adaptation of the female organist to the
pregnancy
and immunological tolerance toward the
fetus
indeed over the three trimesters the
suppressive deregulatory lymphocytes
are progressively more and more
represented while the expression of
costimulatory molecules
decreases over time it is not uncommon
that the less responsive immune system
during pregnancy develops a suboptimal
long-lived response moreover
such adaptation relates to an increased
risk of infection and progression to
severe disease in pregnant women
in fact this subject in the subject
the suboptimal immune response is harder
to be triggered resulting in a lower
ability to control the embedding
pathogen
however upon a missed pathogen clearance
the pro-inflammatory stimuli beat that
and this may then generate an intense
uncoordinated immune response
resembling the inauspicious copyrighted
cytokine storm
of course this graph is an
oversimplification taken to extremes
and it should not be taken for reference
in order to perform this study we're
enrolled
47 pregnant women who acquired subscribe
to infection during the late
third trimester within two weeks before
delivery for most of them
upon delivery blood was drawn at t0
and the following time points at week 2
4 and 24. plasma was obtained
to measure the anti-subscribe to
specific igg
and igm antibodies to perform the actual
neutralization title
and to perform plasmatic and cytokines
and chemokines profiling
moreover pbncs were isolated for
mrna profiling upon starscop2x vivo
stimulation
at the six-month follow-up in the top
left panel
eighty percent of the subject still were
found to be positive to
specific anti-subscribe to igg
tanner on the right shows the amount of
the antibody produced
picked between the second and the fourth
week to then decrease over time
at the bottom you can see that the
authorization title
nicely matched the amount of antibody
produced
indeed this is not granted as not
everyone develops
neutralizing antibodies as you could
also tell
by the subject here in gray
then we profile the mrna expression of a
number of immune and antiviral related
genes
upon invisible subscribe to stimulation
in this case normalized
upon over the non-assimilated ones the
immune activation characterizing the
first time point
resembled the one observed in the
previous experimental model
but then it weighed over time
confirming the mrna data here the
plasmatic level of cytokines and
chemokines
marked with an asterisk of the proteins
that significantly decreased
over time
overall we observed the subject who got
subscribed to infection during pregnancy
developed an efficient antibody driven
immune response
comparable to the general population
mrna profiling obediences
showed an upper activation of
inflammatory pathways
which then fades away over time
cytokines and chemicals profiling plasma
confirms the pro-inflammatory profiles
as seen by the mrna analysis
these data are confirmed by flow
cytometric assessment of the
t-cell-driven
specific response and immunological
memory which are not shown here
but which we hope you can find shown in
the full published manuscript
currently we are planning to take
advantage of the scientific information
we
quickly gathered also thanks to the
methodology we finitude
to unravel other interesting scientific
questions such as
the immune profiling of other peculiar
cores
or the role of suscribe 2 accessory
protein
on host gene expression among other
projects
i would like to thank university of
milan and our collaborators such as
richisakov hospital in milan
polyclinical hospital in milan and term
official centers
thank you for your attention will now be
happy to take
some of your questions
and thank you from nap and claudio for
that informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions
coming in from our audience members our
first question
concerning the pregnant women study did
the enrolled
women display different levels of
severity
in covenanting disease progression and
if so
did you analyze the antibody production
in the subject stratified
by disease severity and was there a
correlation
and thank you for the questions and
indeed we
have different subjects um representing
basically the whole spectrum of disease
severity
and the majority of them was
asymptomatic but we had also some case
of
mild to severe to critical and
disease outcome and
indeed we performed such analysis
although or in the lack of time
we didn't show them in the presentation
and the results clearly showed
that the amount of antibody produced
did not match the grade of severity
because of the widespread
of the measured antibody
titer however considering the
percentage of subjects producing
antibodies
we saw that while in the symptomatic
group
50 only of the subjects and produce
antibodies into the mild to severe
to a critical um group basically
100 percent of them develop
antibodies specific anti-task of two
thank you so much and what is the
sensitivity
of the qg assay
um i'll take that uh thanks for the
question um so
for the quantum genes the quantity nexus
in two different formats the the
quantity in plex
assays um are uh
so the sensitivity is about 1000 rna
copies
per sample per target um and if you go
for a single plexing
method then it is it becomes five times
more sensitive so approximately 200
copies of your target rna so that is the
amount of sensitivity for these assays
thank you very much and
can purified rna be used in the quantity
gene
assay and how well does the result
correlate
to other gene expression measurement
methods such as
qpcr micro arrays and ngs
yeah yeah that's that's a good question
um so yes
the the biggest advantage of quantity in
assays is that
it enables the users to directly go with
samples such as the whole blood tissues
either
fresh frozen or even ffbe embedded
so but apart from that if one has access
to a purified rna sample
of course this can also be uh used uh to
do the multiplexing measurements
um as for the comparison with the with
the standard
gene expression methodology such as qpcr
and even sequencing
there are studies and publications
available which
nicely shows uh uh that the quantitation
assay
data nicely correlates with uh with the
existing methodologies as well
so we very often get a very high
correlation of more than 1995
thank you so much now is there a data
analysis
package for the quantity gene assay
um yes there is a free of
charge data analysis tool that is
available
to be accessed by users on the
thermofisher
cloud if one has a basic
thumb of your account then you can
simply log in
and and have access to this tool where
you directly upload your
raw data in csv format and
there is a place where you can set up
your your plate layout
name them group them if you like and uh
choose the
relevant housekeepers that are inside
already built inside your panel
and do a relative quantification
analysis
thank you so much our next question and
i want to thank again
our audience for these great questions
coming in our next one is
is there a protein multiplex assay
as well that is a good question yes
um so the luminex platform
offers not only uh rna multiplexing but
also
protein multiplexing assays so we at the
fisher
uh have a long-standing experience of
developing both rna and protein
multiplexing assays
and when it comes to protein assays
the the largest available panel is about
65
plex meaning 65 targets that can be
measured in a single reaction
and very often we see uh users uh are
happy to
to sort of match the protein profiling
uh with the mrna profiling so starting
with a protein assay and
finishing with a quantity gene or vice
versa so the answer is yes
you can also do a protein multiplexing
profiling using the loop next technology
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions
our next audience member wants to know
cases of co-infections with different
variants are they known
claudio yes
and among the studies we performed
we did not focus on that and
in literature some are reported but
i've not i don't have any details right
now to answer
this question
thank you very much and can you share a
little bit about
the panels available for other animal
models like
ferrets um
yes i can take that one so the
one other advantage of quantity genesis
is that
you can literally design uh panels
for any species as long as there is a
uh a code with rna mrna
we can uh design panels for
uh for those targets regardless of the
species so yes
thank you so much now why do you think
there are differences in cytokine
cytokin expression stars kobe 2
virus and flu viruses
thank you for the question and
first of all there are different viruses
and
the immunological pathways that they
simulate
might be different but also in the
experiment we've shown before
um cells where pbmc is isolated from
healthy
donors so for sure they were
already exposed to flu viruses in the
past and
usually we use it as a positive control
because almost everyone has been exposed
during his life
and therefore has a memory immunological
memory ready
to be triggered while as they were
healthy donors
that was probably the first exposure of
the cells to cycle too
and so the immunological response is
based on totally different
pathways thank you so much
now concerning the lung transplantation
study subject one displays a
higher pro-inflammatory activated
profile
all along however in the last slide
the ex vivo stimulated pbmcs
the cytokines profile evaluated as
protein released
in the super mutant does not match
what observed at the mrna in the very
same cells
how do you explain such apparent
discrepancy
in particular regarding the il-6
so we noticed that and um
as you noticed subject one
is more activated the
expression profile was higher basically
in any condition at the protein level
and the marine level both in lung and
impedances
even in basic condition with no
stimulation
um probably these uh
the cells from this subject were already
um activated
and the individual stimulation which is
quite strong
by the way produce probably nitro
activation
resulting in exhaustion
other cells and this phenomenon is quite
common
in severe cases of cognitive and this
has been already
observed and published and we are also
going deeper into this kind of analysis
and we
often see exhaustion from the cells and
so they do produce a lot of rna they do
respond
to the stimuli but due to an
uncoordinated and overwhelming
stimulation
they basically do not um
it doesn't result in a productive
expression of the protein level
thank you so much now could you share
what were the exact materials and
methods for the immunological
profiling of sars cov2
so this is kind of a general question i
don't know if it refers to
any particular um study i presented
before
and generally speaking all the material
methods are
published in the paper i cited before
and we based
our experiment on the luminex technology
that works either for mrna expression
with the quantity and kit
and for the protein expression we
the the multiplex for profit so that's
basically our approach
and in order to do that um we store
um 100 000 cells more or less
per condition and they were i mean
suitably
frozen as they were after the experiment
and then we followed
the protocol by thermo fisher for
for the quantity which is really easy
and straightforward and require a
minimal handling
of the samples you can find all the
details
in the published paper thank you very
much and again i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
coming in
for the shone experiment you probably
employed the same
q gene array as there are
some similar targets did you diversify
then the arrays according to the type of
study
and the next part of the question how do
you customize them would you suggest
the qgene technology from a user
perspective
which are the pros and cons and how
practical and user-friendly
is it that's a large question
yeah that's a lot of questions anyway i
try to go over all of them
so um at the beginning when we
basically employ the quantity in
technology really early on
basically in march and was new to us
and so we set up the
methodology with the help of thermo
fisher
um with a remote um
explanation by them and
at the beginning we designed a custom
array based on our previous experiences
on our on other viruses and
based on the first publication that were
coming out of the time
so we basically employed this a lot
wide scanning profiling quantity
basically on
all our projects and
since it was quite successful and we
gathered quickly a lot of data
we then and kept going with the quantity
and we customized even further
and tailored on each single project
so for example the one on
accessory uh gns oscilloscope two
or the one dedicated for the pediatric
or the pregnant women so step by step
we diversified our needs
and um it's really easy to customize
basically
and the the the the sad array
is uh developed by thermofisher
technicians and we just
gave the least of the gene with the
specification
of the particular genome of the
particular region but they then
developed
all the silicon um
testing of our probes and
let me go back to the question a second
and so from my user
point of view um
so it's the approach we found
is that this technology requires
really a minimal handling of samples
meaning
that um we were able to start
from different kinds of specimens
such as biopsies
all blood rna already isolated
and purified tbmc
lines there are different buffers
according to the needs
but there is no rna isolation there is
not a prescription needed so
it's quite straightforward and i think
that main advantage is
that you can perform
in a single test many targets
up to 80 or something and you have the
food plate of 96 well
so of course in like
less than 24 hours from the beginning
to the end the analysis of the data for
80 targets for 96 wealth it's quite
convenient and even though even if the
price is i mean not very
low but considering the amount of
targets and the amount of that
process and the amount of time that is
spared
we found that it's really convenient and
of course it doesn't work for a couple
of targets or a couple of samples
but scaling up with many targets and
many samples
we find it quite friendly
easy to use and fast extremely fast
thank you so much now in regards to
those targets
can i look at them simultaneously
how many can i look at simultaneously
i'll i'll take that so as of
now you can look at 80
unique targets per reaction per sample
that's the maximum size of a panel that
can be built
but what is nice is we recently also
developed the high throughput format of
the assays
classically we did it using a 96 well
plate format
but we also recently have a 384 well
format to improve
uh sample throughput so if you have
multiple samples
to run um you can
you can have them hide either in an
under six well or in a 384 volt format
but the maximum number of targets
is 80. thank you so much now gentlemen
is quantity gene semi quantitative or
quantitative
um so so quantogen is a is a
basically relative quantification method
so by default it is it is relative
quantification
but you can also make it fully
quantitative
if you have for example in vitro
transcribed rna as a reference material
that you can run as a standard curve and
then quantitate your samples
against it so but in a in a
in a regular quantity like i say it's
it's by default a relative
quantification
method thank you so much we have time
for one
more question if you stored plasma
from cougar patients and use in simult
in stimulating normal pbmcs
what additional information might be
gained if you also have stored
pbmcs from the same patient
if you possibly know that
that's an interesting question that we
actually never
thought about and it
is not part actually of our experimental
setting
as we collect multiple samples and then
we stimulate them
in a controlled manner with a certain
amount
of virus and and it's gonna be the same
virus for
all for each sample so that's not
our aim usually and i would also say
that
since we measure mainly the antiviral
response and it's not even
given that um i mean bireemia
for task of two is quite rare and it's
only in severe
to critical cases so it's
it's not our first choice usually for
the aim we have so um
part of our experience but that's an
interesting
point of view thank you so much actually
we have time for one more
considering stars kobe 2 is still so new
how long do you envision follow-up
immune profiling studies
like this taking place it seems like one
of the benefits
of the quantagine assay you spoke about
is a life and go
and i can envision much more follow-up
and additional
organ characterization with all the
long-term
effects
so i think that if i was able to reply
to this question
i would have already the nobel prize
i just kidding but of course it's new
and we don't really know
how long it's gonna
last we have
characterized this cohort of women
up to six months and we are keep going
actually since
six months or a few months ago we are
keep connecting data
i seen in the literature that
one year follow-up or ten-month
follow-up
um is quiet i mean
studies already and
[Music]
um for sure
um as the second part of the question
is uh
yes for sure it's uh
the quantitation is a suitable
technology
for the lies and goal or additional
organ characterization and
although it's not the
experimental section we usually use as
we stimulate
the cells but
[Music]
that's that's probably uh really easy to
perform with
this kind of technology
thank you so much and primitive and
claudio i want to thank you so much for
your presentation today
would you like to provide any closing
remarks
to our audience before we go i'll start
with you claudio
well thank you and um
i would say that it was a really
interesting session of question and
answer
and we covered many interesting topics
and um would say that we
as in as said in my
conclusion slide that we are
expanding the number of projects and
employing
the quantigen and
this has been quite helpful along
and you know we would like to thank the
thermo fisher for
their support which was really useful
for all of this project i presented you
and for all the coming project i hope
you can
soon find published
thank you so much claudio and premiere
would you like to add any remarks
um yes uh so firstly thank you uh to all
the audience for all their very nice
interesting questions
and also uh to you for for hosting this
session
so yeah and a big thank you to claudio
our collaborator who has done some
excellent work and it was a pleasure
working with him
um uh over the last uh several months
in in in getting all these papers and
and interesting results out
so uh yeah we are um
very excited that qanta gene uh was uh
able to uh to help uh claudio anders and
his team
to to uh to come up with some some very
interesting observations in this study
um yeah that's uh that's all i would
like to say thank you
well i want to thank you both again from
nat and claudio for your time
and for your important research and i
also want to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for writing on today's
educational webcast before we go i want
to thank our audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions and
remind you that questions we did not
have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone
stay safe and stay healthy bye